[Música]
amaba ese número
un espacio de dos ahí arriba suspendidos
sus líneas y esquinas rojas nosotros
tienen de nuestra intimidad dos que se
buscan en el espacio reducido y colgante
se acercan se recogen se acarician se
evitan se cruzan se balancean con fuerza
silencio en el equilibrio respirar
volverá el desencuentro escapar
el paso a sus brazos por los muslos de
ella ella suelta las barras
el impulso no llega el giro no termina
no se alcanzan vacío impacto dolor
intenso confusión instantes perdidos en
el más allá
el cuerpo partido en dos
estoy ahí
con mucho dolor
llegan los bomberos me amarran a la
camilla y siento que la mitad de mi
cuerpo ha desaparecido
una vez internada sigo sin poder mover
mis piernas
no me puedo mover y a mi alrededor hay
muchas máquinas que me mantienen estable
y amortiguar un poco el dolor
voy pasando por diferentes pruebas
y mi mente está sumergida en un solo
pensamiento
me he fallado
aun cuando escucho el diagnóstico no
puedo terminar de entender lo que está
sucediendo fractura de columna con
compresión de la médula espinal
porque me ha pasado esto
vamos a presentar este número más de 40
veces lo habíamos hecho en un festival
en brasil
nada podía detenerme
o sí
había fallado y fallar es aún más
doloroso cuando no has contemplado la
posibilidad del error
la vida puede dar un giro radical en
menos de un segundo si no te das el
tiempo de cuidar algunos detalles
lo que separa un instante del otro es la
posibilidad de que todo siga su rumbo o
de que todo cambie para siempre
desde ese día mi cuerpo llevaría la
carga de un sello muy pesado llamado
secuelas irreversibles
y reversible significa que no hay vuelta
atrás
no te queda otra que enfrentar la
realidad del presente
pero no falles solamente yo al caer
éramos un grupo de seis personas los que
estábamos en esa obra y fuimos todos
nosotros los que no pudimos prever que
no somos perfectos que no tenemos la
vida asegurada y mientras yo luchaba por
mi vida en una cama cada uno de nosotros
iba sintiendo las consecuencias de este
error
hay situaciones que te revuelcan y no
sabes cómo afrontarlas
a veces intentamos subir tapando lo que
sentimos intentando voltear la página
porque a los humanos nos cuesta tanto
enfrentar nuestros errores
porque a veces es tan difícil hacernos
cargo de lo que nos duele
cuando recibo las visitas y hablamos de
cualquier cosa y llenando el vacío
siento que eso no me sirve
voy sintiendo como en el grupo cada uno
va viviendo lo que acaba de suceder
desde su instinto el compañero que había
realizado el dúo conmigo en un arranque
de frustración y dolor decide irse del
imm a perderse entre los apus de cusco y
gritar ahí su dolor para poder enfrentar
lo que había sucedido
el sentimiento de culpa también se
apodera de mi directora por no haberme
podido cuidar y puedo sentir en su
mirada su preocupación por mi futuro
ella también se toma una distancia
porque verme paralizada la sobrepasa
completamente
después de un tiempo decidimos juntarnos
poder hablar de lo que cada uno había
vivido desde mi caída compartir
las heridas los miedos los vacíos para
darnos una oportunidad de ir cerrando
las heridas
y así fuimos sintiendo alivio de poder
abrazarnos de poder estar ahí todos
juntos
uno de mis compañeros me cuenta que
siempre recuerda el último día que nos
encontramos llegando al ensayo
él me dijo voy un ratito a la bodega
listo te espero abajo le dije me dice
entre lágrimas que todos los días
llegando se entrenamiento por un segundo
piensa que me va a encontrar ahí abajo
como yo le dije
pero yo no estoy en ese momento ni él ni
yo sabemos si volveré
pero en todo caso me reconforta saber
que me está esperando
vamos entendiendo como grupo que llorar
está bien
que la frustración por no poder volver
atrás va a ir pasando en medida que
entendamos que no somos perfectos que no
tenemos el futuro asegurado
y desde ese lugar nos perdonamos
por no haber entendido que podíamos
fallar
y decidimos darnos la oportunidad de
seguir encontrándonos de compartir
nuevas alegrías y así aligerar la carga
repartiendo el peso entre todos porque
yo no quiero ser el recuerdo de lo que
salió mal quiero ser el aviso de que
siempre podemos aprender a mejorar
todo esto sucedía mientras yo hacía mi
propio proceso de recuperación
y así como en el grupo nos dimos la
oportunidad de encontrarnos yo también
necesitaba darme una oportunidad
pero que implicaba eso darme una
oportunidad sí pero de qué
yo amaba ese número así como amaba lo
que sabía hacer pero estando
hospitalizada
me sentía muy lejos el acróbata que
podía volar sujetada por sus pies
quién soy ahora antes cuando alguien me
preguntaba que era yo podía responder
sin dudar soy bailarina
pero ahora cómo responder a esa pregunta
me puedo seguir considerando bailarina o
acróbata
como me hago cargo de todo este vacío si
soy diferente dejo de ser yo
cómo sobrevivir esta experiencia si me
siento tan perdida como recuperarme si
mi cuerpo se siente tan asustado que
significa recuperarse
volverá a ser la misma de antes
eso ya no es posible
pero no dejo de pensar cómo puedo hacer
para recuperar lo que más me importa mi
día a día mi trabajo
mi casa mi cuerpo
quizás la primera oportunidad que me doy
es no tener respuestas claras y entonces
decido enfocarme en mi rehabilitación
después de haber pasado más de un mes
internada haber pasado por dos cirugías
puedo por fin entrar al centro de
rehabilitación
es muy duro pensar que me voy a quedar
ahí por 5 meses cuando lo que más
quisiera es estar en mi casa con mi
familia al lado
los días van pasando y voy entendiendo
como cada pequeño logro va sumando por
más pequeño que sea
voy entendiendo también como la
paciencia y la perseverancia son
indispensables
aunque es cierto en que hay días en que
cuando se pregunta para qué esforzarse
de tanto porque no tirar la toalla y
hacia el final sabes que nunca vas a
poder hacer una vida como la de antes
los pacientes que conviven conmigo
muchas veces no se dan cuenta de la
oportunidad que significa cada terapia
por las distintas realidades de la que
viene cada uno muchos sienten como si
esto fuera un castigo de la vida
yo intento alentarlos y en silencio
agradezco que el entrenamiento de circo
me haya permitido tener la disciplina
que en ese momento necesito
decido darle toda mi energía a mi
recuperación
puedo darme cuenta como mi entusiasmo
por avanzar por descubrir formas de
despertar mis músculos se contagian en
mi terapeuta
él también se inventa ejercicio me
sumerge en el agua y está dispuesto a
celebrar conmigo cada logro
reafirmó lo largo de este camino como se
influencian mutuamente
las emociones el cuerpo y la mente
parece una publicidad de formación
holística pero es de verdad la conexión
más potente que podría tener para salir
adelante
siento la presión del tiempo porque
algunos médicos me dicen que tengo que
aprovechar que es sobre todo en el
primer año en el que uno puede dar la
mayor cantidad de avances son esos
mismos médicos los que me preguntan a
qué me dedico cuando les respondo que
soy bailarina la respuesta de ellos es
devastadora
tendrás que dedicarte a otra cosa
y yo me quedo sin respuestas
siento que ellos me dicen eso porque no
me conocen y si viene sé que este camino
de recuperación no es una línea recta
sino que está compuesta por muchas
subidas y bajadas físicas y emocionales
yo quiero intentarlo
darme la oportunidad de poder volver a
hacer mi vida mi carrera
no tengo muy claro cómo lo voy a lograr
pero sí sé lo que la creatividad es
capaz de hacer
lograr resultados inesperados con los
recursos que uno tiene y además es
importante poner a prueba las ideas
mientras tanto decido enfocarme en mi
rehabilitación como si este fuera el
número más importante de mi vida volver
a pararme
con mi pierna izquierda más fortalecida
y mi organismo más estable empiezo a
probar algunas cosas más allá de la
terapia tradicional me he hecho en una
colchoneta y empiezo a rodar como si
fuera un bebé o como una alumna de danza
para principiantes
me siento torpe y tengo mucho miedo de
aplastar mi pierna porque si bien
algunos músculos van queriendo despertar
desde mi lesión no ha podido volver a
sentir mi pierna en absoluto
no es como si tuviera un hormigueo no
está completamente dormida
y lo que siento son calambres llamados
dolores neuropáticos y aunque son una
sensación extraña un poco molesta o
bastante molesta a veces es la única
referencia sensorial que tengo de mi
pierna
y aunque sean como una especie de
cortocircuitos voy aprendiendo a
convivir con ellos voy avanzando y toda
esta información va sumando en mi cuerpo
hasta que llegó el día mi terapeuta me
dice que es el momento de intentar
caminar intentar me muero de nervios
pero no hay peor intento que que no se
haga con convicción
con mi pierna derecha sostenida por una
férula para proteger mi rodilla y mi
tobillo me quedo parada al borde de unas
barras paralelas que marcan un camino de
unos cuantos metros pero en ese momento
yo lo veo como un túnel infinito
empiezo a dar algunos pasos y siento que
me es que se pierde a cada rato de nuevo
tengo mucho miedo de caerme pero
continuo
después de un tiempo estoy listo para
dar el siguiente paso
mi terapeuta me espera con unos bastones
canadienses
me dice que no me puede prometer que
vaya a dejar la silla de ruedas por los
bastones pero que vamos a hacer todo lo
posible para que mi cuerpo gane
resistencia y mejore su equilibrio
estando de pie
me parece increíble como después de
haberme colgado de mil maneras haber
hecho todo tipo de equilibrios
y ponerme de pie estando en una posición
tan simple y cotidiana en ese momento me
implica un gran esfuerzo y me hace tomar
conciencia de la cantidad de músculos
que están comprometidos en esta posición
mi cabeza se cansa rápidamente de mandar
tantas órdenes como pueda para que mi
espalda no me halle para atrás para que
mi pierna izquierda que es la fuerte no
colapse para que mis brazos no abusen
del apoyo en los bastones
descanso respiro me alimento revisa mi
mente lo experimentado y vuelvo a probar
y poco a poco voy haciendo un recorrido
cada vez más largo acompañada de cerca
por mi terapeuta o por mi pareja que
viene todos los días a verme al centro
de rehabilitación
un día parada frente a un espejo yo
estaba esperando un ascensor
me vi
y de pronto me costó reconocerme me
sentía muy distinta esto soy yo
la nueva yo
por primera vez me reconocí como una
persona con discapacidad
en las calles también puedo sentir las
miradas de algunas personas que me
observan con curiosidad
muchos también con lástima
como si les asustará reflejarse en mí
tan rara me veo frente a su normalidad
después de más de un año de haber
empezado mi rehabilitación me encuentro
con algunas personas que me siguen
recomendando hacer esto o lo otro que no
deje de hacer más terapias para si yo me
pueda recuperar y que por fin dejé mis
bastones
son esas mismas personas también que me
invitan insistentemente a que me siente
como si yo no pudiera decidir en qué
momento descansar
a veces me invade el ímpetu de algunas
personas que me dejan a un costado como
si yo fuera incapaz de probar hacer las
cosas a mi manera mi propio ritmo o en
todo caso de pedir ayuda cuando la
necesito
no siempre reacciona de la misma manera
a veces me cansa sentir que me tratan
diferente
otras veces tengo la claridad y la calma
para explicar que tengo una parálisis y
que esta es una condición que me
acompaña no me define pero si acompaña
una parte de mi vida
me pregunto si algún día me acostumbraré
a este no yo me pregunto si es cuestión
de resignarse
pero siento que la resignación
me ata una nostalgia de lo que un día
fui
y entonces qué significa recuperarse
voy entrando a una etapa en la que
siento que soy una nueva versión de mí
misma ni mejor ni peor que antes solo
distinta he perdido algunas habilidades
convencionales pero he ganado otras muy
propias adaptadas a mí
adaptadas a mi cuerpo
mi cuerpo distinto al tuyo
distinto al mío de antes
mi cuerpo que necesita que le dedique
tiempo y espacio consciente para volver
a conocerlo
todo lo demás puede desaparecer o
cambiar pero mi cuerpo va a seguir
siendo el mío y si estoy viva es porque
tengo un cuerpo que vive y si estoy viva
es para darme la oportunidad de
rehabilitarlo
entiendo que mi esencia sigue siendo la
misma mi pasión por la danza no ha
cambiado
mis amores siguen latentes sigo siendo
yo
entonces
me encuentro con la oportunidad que
estaba buscando
me atrevo a volver a bailar
con mucha curiosidad por ir descubriendo
mi nueva forma de moverme entregándome
al placer
descubriendo cómo hacer mi movimiento
con los bastones
me voy dando cuenta que puedo
reconciliar me conmigo misma
imperfecta a mi manera imperfecta como
cualquier otro individuo
así
voy trazando una nueva ruta
y los miedos que antes aparecían de vez
en cuando como sombras se van alejando
para darle espacio una confianza que
cada vez se va haciendo más grande
dos años después de mi lesión mi hermana
me propone crear una obra
a finales del 2016 con el cuerpo
vibrando de emoción nervios y adrenalina
vuelvo al escenario con territorio
vertical una obra en la que comparto con
el público mi camino por reconstruir mi
cuerpo por reconquistar lo integrando
mis bastones a mi danza y enriqueciendo
la calidad de mi movimiento por la
simetría de mis piernas para así romper
los prejuicios que existen hacia las
personas con discapacidad
como una semilla que va germinando
un año después fundamos mundanas
una compañía que nace para crear y
producir obras de danza y movimiento
en la que podamos generar espacios
seguros para la diversidad de cuerpos y
perspectivas
para la es cuestión a miento hacia lo
diferente y para la integración de
diversos lenguajes
así
me permito resignificar mi vida
y tener el valor de continuar y
encontrar nuevas formas
de darle un sentido a tu vida
es la cara más bonita que he encontrado
en la discapacidad
esta es la misma cara que encuentro en
cualquier otro ser humano que frente al
error
se permite una nueva oportunidad para
seguir aprendiendo para disfrutar
para buscar tu pasión cuál es tu pasión
creo que siempre puedes darte un espacio
para buscarla y que sea parte de tu vida
creo que los cambios previstos o
imprevistos son una gran puerta para
desarrollar nuevas facetas
hace 5 años
que estoy dando mis clases porque estoy
convencida de que el arte es una
herramienta poderosa para incluir a las
minorías y para reducir nuestras brechas
sociales
la vida sigue y los retos crecen
desde hace 4 meses mi mayor reto es
haberme convertido en mamá
una pequeñita que cuando me llama sonríe
antes de verme porque reconoce el sonido
particular de mis pasos
sé que trilce y yo tendremos nuestra
propia forma de hacer las cosas a
nuestro propio ritmo iremos aprendiendo
juntas y en vez de enfocarme en lo que
no puedo hacer con ella
sé que puedo romper mis esquemas
para encontrar mi propia forma de
enseñarle a caminar en este mundo
gracias
[Aplausos]